Now, unlike our usual ending to the lesson with a recap, let's try to meditate
and see if you can do it and you can leave in a stress free, relaxed state.
First, you want to sit with your eyes closed in a comfortable position. Slowly
breathe in for a count of four. Hold for two seconds and then breath through
your nose releasing. You want to take long breaths in and then long breaths
out. While you're breathing, remember to try to not let anything pop into your
head, it maybe helpful to think about the ocean waves coming in as you're
breathing. And then as your exhaling, the wave's going back out. Try to do this
for five minutes a day, moving up to fifty minutes a day. Research has shown
that if you can meditate, you may be able to reduce your stress levels